le pg en a où ces forçats de la route
comment les appeler on fait ça il ya
cent ans et buvait de la bière qui
s'endormait je suis pas faussé il
finissait définissez les routes étaient
pas goudronnées respect respect tu viens
pour que le tour de france bourgogne et
50000 course ils s'en foutent du tour de
france qui compte ne serait que de
participer c'est à peine si je
l'espérais je n'avais jamais vu la
montagne de ma vie de même que la
meilleure d'ailleurs
[Musique]
je crève je donne mon vélo avec le
maître les stopper le vélo je l'engueulé
j'avais engueulé avec c'était un tronc
d'arbre
tu t'es même pas un mec comment elle
était tellement j'étais fatigué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'équipe seuls quotidiens sportifs de
l'hexagone continue d'enregistrer 60 ans
après sa fondation une hausse de ses
ventes au moment du tour de france mais
sa naissance ne fut pas les plus simples
m
à la libération l'auto est interdite
comme la plupart des titres parus durant
l'occupation
les biens du groupe le parc des princes
et le vélodrome d'hiver sont mis sous
séquestre y compris le label tour de
france jacques godet son directeur qui
s'est vu retirer sa carte de journaliste
va alors trouver un soutien crucial en
la personne d'emilien amaury l'un des
fondateurs de la presse clandestine sous
l'occupation et directeur du tout récent
parisien libéré le 28 février 1946
l'équipe un nouveau quotidien de sport
dirigé en sous-main par jacques goddet
sort dans les kiosques
quelques mois plus tard emilie à un
gorille obtient des pouvoirs publics
l'entière réhabilitation de jacques
goddet et lui propose une association
entre leurs deux quotidiens pour
relancer le tour de france
j'ai trouvé ça très heureux que le franc
suisse est appuyé par un grand journal
d'information qui apporte c'est donc aux
éléments publicitaires et d un support
supplémentaire et valorisant le rapport
et leurs efforts et emilien et et moi on
leur serre ont fait les frais on imagine
l'anxiété de jacques goddet ce 25 juin
la nouvelle génération du public après
sept années d'interruption sera-t-il au
rendez-vous et l'ancienne sera t'elle
aussi fidèle à l'équipe qu'elle le fût
un auto
[Musique]
c'est marcel cerdan qui donne à l'arc de
triomphe le départ du tour de france et
le premier depuis la guerre 100 coureurs
français belge et luxembourgeois italien
et lens pour l'attendre on limite il
s'est surtout quand c'est parce que
c'est robin qui le gagne mais me fallait
voir le monde qui a mis c'était mort de
membres de partout c'était la fête
c'était la joie c'était on avait redonné
le tour de france aux français et pas
pour des ambitions bien et lazaridès
attaquent le col de l'izoard
derrière eux ils tombent relâche à pied
au col d'allos il passe au commandement
avec les arrivées de tandem procès ne
sera pas rejoint
[Musique]
vous savez viêt on s'était voix
magnifique et bien entendu nous jeunes à
l'admiration devant bientôt parce que
lui tôt attention à l'époque c'était
vous savez c'était poulidor c'était
bénin peut-être au-dessus de pluie d'or
c'était la france s'en tirait bien que
bientôt sur la route et saint brieuc
étape contre la montre était considéré
par beaucoup comme devant décider en
dernier ressort du résultat final du
tour dès les premiers chronos métrage on
s'apercevait que le belge hymne panis et
détente est
mais dans son fief robbie qui lui
disputait chèrement la victoire
toutefois ils bannissent devait
l'emporter de plus tandis que vietto
fatigué par ses efforts précédents
abandonner son maillot jaune à l'italien
brand il ya toi voulu l'a voulu à batman
est rentré chez lui en fin ça a été si
l'on m'avait dit avant je vous ai dit
comme faisait chambre ensemble
à l'époque il y avait le spicg ra comme
un changement qu'elle a qui étaient
venus à la chambre supplier veto qui
l'abandonna pam fait cinéma il met la
valise dans l'ascenseur il descend d'un
étage a augmenté en fait ça a duré un
quart d'heure si mal
ils ont fait pleurer me font sentir et à
la france car plus là devant son poste
en écoutant gens joyeux plaindre la
perte du maillot devrait bientôt changer
week-end lui ce qu'il a compris tout de
suite c'était ce qu'il fallait dans une
course cycliste raconter des coureurs
raconté les faits de course
être ami avec les coureurs ce que
n'était pas jean antoine
très ami avec les directeurs sportifs
être ami avec les organisateurs et
surtout savoir ce qu'il nous a toujours
dit à nous être le photographe de
l'instantané ils vont bientôt de la
santé de tous les jours heureux dans
quatre ans toujours en tête ont pas de
nous apercevrons là bas
la tour eiffel la torpeur qui signifie
que le taux de prendre face est terminée
et des quatre enfants qui l'ont inventé
voici qui maintenant les lambris de la
place aborderont sans son accord dans la
vie de la reine
je demande à jean teater qu'il entend on
par ses pointes de se tenir prêts à
prendre le relais
car maintenant arrive entendre
l'acclamation populaire qui va déferler
gestion l'apartheid mais voici que les
coups de sifflet retentit
ce direct radiophonique a été une
révolution dans l'histoire du tour de
france et des médias pour la première
fois il est possible de rentrer à
l'intérieur de la course en mouvement
dans les dix derniers kilomètres
c'est à dire de s'affranchir de sa
furtivité de faire vivre aux auditeurs
ces péripéties dans sa continuité ce que
ni les actualités cinématographiques ni
la presse ne peuvent réussir
[Musique]
la radio n'empêche pas pour autant
l'explosion des ventes de l'équipe et
son directeur de s'en féliciter
à côté de ces coureurs qui ont triomphé
des embûches et des peines de la route à
côté de robic vainqueur qui a été
empoigné sa victoire à bras le corps et
qu'il a serrés à l'étouffée il y à un
autre magnifique gagnant le tout
l'intention de des granges a été
magnifié distraire et communiqué de
l'entousiasme par l'exemple d'une
bataille sincère ou l'homme prouve qu'il
sait tout endurer pour atteindre le but
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le journaliste se débrouilla parfait
propres moyens se battait pour
l'information se battait pour avoir des
lignes téléphoniques
j'ai vu des tgv italiens trépigner dans
leur cabine avant la communication est
tout aussi ton et c'était encore à
nouveau une horde attente pour que la
ligne soit rétabli on a parlé de
l'époque héroïque dans les années 1910
puis d'un format pour les coureurs mais
la reprise du tour à à partir de mai car
en fait c'était l'époque héroïque pour
les journalistes
5000 km 21 étapes deux équipes était le
35e tour de france cycliste dont le
départ a été donné à saint cloud à 120
champions après avoir longé la scène
les coureurs traversent au roi en trombe
franchissement d'eau de mer où elles
sont encouragées par le régional bourvil
tous les yeux se tendent sur le champion
italien gino bartali numéro 31 qui
justifie sa réputation le tour de france
à l'origine propriété exclusive d'un
journal de sport dépend maintenant d'une
gestion bicéphale jacques goddet pour
l'équipe et félix lévitan rédacteur en
chef de la rubrique sportive du parisien
libéré imposé par emilien amaury
le tour reste avant tout une affaire de
journalistes de presse écrite une
vitrine pour la promotion d'un journal
de sport
c'est beaucoup plus difficile tout ça
nous paraissait facile et amusant et
amusant même temps et puis là on nous
sommes tout de suite on a eu la chance
aussi de tomber tout de suite avec de
grands coureurs parce que j'ai avec moi
j'ai fait mes débuts avec l'épopée avec
les copies avec les bars thani a eu ces
gens là on s'est trouvé tout de suite
vraiment plonger si vous voulez aa une
des ventes époque du site le 15 juillet
à cannes
les jeux semblent faits louis baubet un
jeune breton s'empare pour la huitième
fois consécutive du maillot jaune
bartali dit gino le pieux est relégué à
20 minutes du français
mais le plus dur est à venir
les montagnes alpines lieu épique du
tour de france à meerab le mans dépeinte
par le dessinateur fétiche de l'équipe
pelos avec ses sorcières aux dents
vertes et ses juges de paix il était
écrit que beauvais ne gagnerait pas ce
tour à cause d'un furoncle et d'une
guerre civile larvée
en italie le tour de france tourne dans
ce sens là 1 les pyrénées les alpes le
tour de france fait étape à cannes le 14
juillet 1948 et on apprend qu'un
attentat a eu lieu contre thau grille
est le leader du parti communiste
italien lundi va mourir 1 les
journalistes les coureurs italiens
disent et le moment c'est la révolution
on rentre en italie et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que gino le pieux a
été à fait partie des jeunesses
catholiques et il a fréquenté de gasperi
qui est président du conseil italien en
48 et barsali reçoit un coup de
téléphone de son ami de gasperi le
macama de monitor un jeune indien inde
au mal et votre brosse à dents avec pato
la scène célébrera les fans avec louis
chavanes décombres faisait le break les
ben ali
on a définitivement ses prétentions au
maillot jaune et les prési d'un seul
coup les espoirs de tous ses adversaires
et au fait la pole sein d'attac bay pum
kent au budget de m produire du losc à
paris et que je vois ton fils à bérenx
le lecteur de ben ali n'a pas cependant
ce sens que les jeunes bovins se
défendit jusqu'à la limite de ses forces
ali grève rebelles est seul poursuivi
par un premier peloton
mais la pallice non dans une chose
extraordinaire remonte tout le monde est
resté encore l'exploit de gagner l'étape
et c'est à peine si j'ai mal à
m'intégrer 20-15 habitués allez au zoo
loris nery à lui tout seul comme
animateur belgique 2002 les singuliers
morte
nous on est inquiet v marthe ali gagne
le tour dix ans après sa première
victoire et l'italie qui s'est
enthousiasmé une semaine durant en a
oublié ses désordres intérieurs
ici la légende d'henri desgrange
s'enrichit d'une page qui dépasse les
frontières du sport même peut-être aussi
celle de ce bas monde
[Musique]
l'étape dans le sa bénédiction
apostolique au maillot jaune de 1948 la
presse bien que talonné par la radio a
encore de beaux jours devant elle sur le
tour 1949
l'équipe innove en décidant d'ouvrir
quotidiennement ses colonnes aux
confidences d'un jeune coureur français
jacques marinelli qui réussit l'exploit
de conserver six jours durant le maillot
jaune
[Musique]
j'ai été le corps ce qui a fait le plus
fort tirage du journal l'équipe en 40
ans et le troisième de tous sports
confondus c'est à dire derrière marcel
cerdan et l'équipe de france de football
pendant trois jours l'équipe a tiré à
plus de je ne sais plus près de sept
cent mille exemplaires c'était le plus
fort tirage
donc ça veut dire que c'est là le
palmarès mais associée à la popularité à
la notoriété ça vraiment ça fait plaisir
d'être aimé par les gens c'est agréable
le coureur est peut-être cette époque
donc encore plus que maintenant avait
vraiment la notion que ce n'est pas
donné pas tellement ce qu'il posait qui
était important c'était ce qu'on allait
andy rhis qu'on allait en écrire
je n'irai le journaliste pour le coureur
à cette époque là était le complément
absolument indispensable
la révision n'est pas y être pas la
télévision
enfin pas la télévision que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
pourtant lors de la diffusion du journal
télévisé de 20 heures le 1er juillet 49
pierre sabbagh annonce un résumé en
images de la première étape du tour de
france
ces images ont été filmées la veille par
un cameraman sur moto et sont commentés
en direct par georges de caunes
la télévision n'existe pratiquement pas
en estime qu' à 15 cents personnes quand
un poste de télévision
donc le salk la touche personnes dans le
mini personne ne s'éclate et du jour
arrive je dis à ma mère je travaille à
la télévision et à toulouse je suis pas
ce que c'est que la télévision dit
quelle étrange travail qu'est ce que
c'est que la télévision un terrain en
cette fin des années 40
c'est toujours dans les cinémas que l'on
vient s'informer sur le tour la descente
est difficile le seul mauvais
[Musique]
bichot dans la descente est gagnant
[Applaudissements]
des pinces
line renaud du canada
[Applaudissements]
copie à gagner le défense été remis les
accueils de gimat au graphique ça dure
deux minutes
chaque semaine c'est dépassé par par les
événements elle dans les jours les
images du cinéma atteint ce que les
nôtres en deux jours or un jour elle
chante prêche prix immédiates si très
peu de foyers ont le privilège de suivre
le numéro de duettistes coppi bartali
dans leur salon en revanche de plus en
plus de passionnés se retrouvent devant
les vitrines des magasins ou s'attarde
dans les cafés qui ont investi dans
l'achat d'un poste récepteur
en ce début des années 50
la télévision ne peut certes pas encore
prétendre capter l'immédiateté de la
course comme la radio ou donné le soir
ou le lendemain matin analyses et
résultats comme la presse quotidienne
une course autant il néanmoins déclaré
et au fil de ces évolutions
technologiques la télévision est en
train de gagner irrésistiblement du
terrain sur ses concurrents à pays qu il
fallait attendre que le train que le
train soit à l'heure et que le garçon
qui s'appelle hervé ne soit pas endormi
il a veillé longtemps pour à tort la
pellicule
et puis la tranchée culte chiites au
studio de cognac g il ya inversion qui
la sort de sagan mais qui acquit à
develop ou qu'il a l'art au sort qui
ressort l'image et angibaud entre en
scène en vo sous la main le petit ou
sachets la cigarette c'est un personnage
prodigieux de la télévision chez le
couturier il va sortir un événement il
va alimenter en me le donne à visionner
ce film et j'ai quelquefois diminué
quelque fois une heure pour préparer mon
commentaire donc on va le projeter dans
le journal et je serai off comme
toujours je suis une voix qui traduisent
par des mots jusqu'aux images à porte et
cherche à prolonger un petit peu à la
qualité du mal à l'extrême facilité avec
laquelle la télévision est en train à
son tour de s'approprier la légende créé
par henri desgrange 50 ans plus tôt
tiens toujours à ce pouvoir de
fascination d'identification du public
avec les personnages principaux de ce
spectacle les coureurs
sur les routes de ponts dansant se
soucient bien peu du tour de france on
n'a plus qu'une idée en tête se
rafraîchir et par tous les moyens
[Musique]
dans la région de toulon c'est la chasse
aux traditionnels canet et puis comme
dans toute bonne légende
au milieu de ces héros encore humain de
ces argonautes surgi d'un jason un
ulysse qui tutoie les lieux le numéro un
dans les résultats c'est eddy merckx
mais il ya pour moi quelque chose que tu
te mets moins quelqu'un qui soit utile
mais heureux ces photocopies
parce que c'est manifester dans les
conditions qui étaient qui atteignait le
divin qui éteignait le surhomme à sa
morphologie sa nature physics d'êtres
humains et omar peut-être un sanguin
ayant des idées et membres extrêmement
bas des jambes très mince mais une
capacité pulmonaire et norma thorax
considérable c'est ce qui d'ailleurs
face de lui une sorte de volatiles ce
qui explique peut-être beaucoup le
les exploitent il a pu accomplir en
montagne
[Musique]
toujours
il
[Musique]
devant les belges au caire à fait licite
postes d'emploi ville
[Musique]
copie à mal dont ma mère n'ont été fait
pour faire du vélo comme peut l'être est
fait pour faire du football comme comme
serdar été fait pour boxer comme senna
et prost était fait pour piloter
il ya toujours un gars qui dans un sport
elle clac et le leader il est
inaccessible
il est celui que tout le monde voudrait
être il est l'exemple
il avait 58 d'avant ça on avait 15 jours
prendre un pari c'était tragique trajet
qui le devance de terreur chief in
écrasé par lui j'ai donc décidé que ils
auraient tous les gains du premier prix
mais je casse leur concours et qu'on je
considérais comme vainqueur au tour de
france ce week-end est second et que ce
second ray les prix le premier au début
des années 50
le tour de france n'est plus seulement
la vitrine sportive de l'équipe et du
parisien libéré dès son redémarrage en
47 jacques goddet a repris la formule de
desgranges avec des équipes nationales
qui courent sur du matériel fourni par
l'organisation et un financement qui
fait appel aux villes étapes et surtout
un des marques extra sportives qui loue
des places dans la caravane publicitaire
précédent les coureurs
[Musique]
on se presse autour des battures
un cinéma au développement ultra rapide
projette le film de l'étape 3 heures
après l'arrivée
mais les chanteurs relève la palme et
les plus grandes vedettes ont été
convoqués au rendez-vous de cette grande
joie populaire
prenez chante la mer à toutes les étapes
[Musique]
mais très vite
l'inflation des frais d'organisation
oblige godet il évitant à ouvrir encore
plus largement les portes du tour aux
publicitaires dès 1948 une marque de
lainage synthétique attribue une rente
quotidienne de dix mille francs au
porteur du maillot jaune et l'année
suivante c'est autour d'un apéritif et
d'une eau gazeuse de patronner le
challenge international et le grand prix
de la montagne
yvette horner est tu vas marc le maillot
jaune savez yvette horner qui a
maintenant le l'accordéon là à l'époque
c'était une super nana encore maintenant
et moi j'étais un peu un peu
elle me plaisait beaucoup puis
j'attendais j'attendais et du temps 30
secondes et maillot jaune il était marié
à la fille que tu t'es tout à sir le
soir mes compères il avait déjà mangé
j'étais toujours dans l'air mais la
glace et je me regardais avec ce maillot
jaune je vais d'ailleurs encore à la
maison c'était en les nl c'était assez
assez serré ce truc-là aullène son fils
et j'ai dormi avec le maillot j'ai gardé
toute la nuit le maillot jaune et j'ai
même pas changé de maillot de corps j'ai
gardé mon collant les chaussettes et le
maillot jaune je me regardais j'étais
tellement admirée c'était tellement
admiratif devant moi je me plaisait mais
que se passe-t-il au maillot jaune lui
dire deux pays aujourd'hui ses efforts
d'hier où il n'en peut plus voilà qu'il
ait là qu'il abandonnait di cicco bonne
idée ça un morceau et ça a l'air de lui
faire plaisir
allez un autre morceau ça y est ça va
beaucoup mieux allez hop remis tout le
paquet mais oui mon gt1 et il repart
mais c'est extraordinaire il grimpe le
col à une allure encore le relais
vivaient ensemble mais maintenant que
des sondés qui ne
il a pas plus second cup a gagné l'aco
l'équipe de france va marcher
nous allons demander à louison bobet de
nous parler de son alimentation à lui je
mange beaucoup de poissons du vin pur
aussi j'aime beaucoup ma bouteille de
vin par jour est alors beaucoup de
légumes et végétarien louison bobet bien
que participant pour la sixième fois
l'épreuve et le prototype d'une nouvelle
génération certes toujours issus des
milieux populaires mais beaucoup plus à
l'aise dans la gestion de son rôle
médiatique de champion
au tour de france moderne a beaucoup
changé et n'entend on arrivait d'un tour
de france avec une condition physique
par maximum n'est ce pas au maximum
puisque maintenant il faut être en
condition depuis la première étape
jusqu'à derniers temps c'est d'amsterdam
capitale des canaux et des moules avant
que s'est envolé la 41e randonnée
classique des traditionnels géants de la
aux robes et vainqueur de l'an dernier
démarrera avec le maillot jaune qu'il
espère bien malgré les plaisanteries de
problèmes rencontrés en 54 ce tour 1954
voit l'arrivée d'antoine blondin un tout
jeune romancier qui inaugure la première
de ses 524 chronique sur le tour pour
l'équipe
ce qui m'a tout s'est étonnée c'était
son intérêt pour les champions est très
tôt je les amener au domicile de louison
mais c'est dur d'imaginer que quelqu'un
comme antoine blondin
regardez louison lorsqu'on déjeuner chez
maison comme le père noël avec des yeux
d'enfants devant le père noël et il
avait des fulgurances c'était incroyable
il savait tout il devinait tout et même
l'alchimie du cyclisme il comprenait
tout
[Applaudissements]
en 1955
louison bobet est en passe de gagner
pour la troisième fois l'épreuve
égalisant le record du belge philippe
thys en 1920 la montée du ventoux le 18
juillet et le clou de l'épopée boétienne
et antoine blondin en sera le barde
[Musique]
les cigales chantent est la caravane
passe on quitte à cette provence au
masque d'ingratitude pour gravir dans le
silence le ventoux qui fait aux alpilles
comme une monstrueuse verrue rugueuse et
rouge au blanc au fil de l'ascension
l'effectif se décantait les hommes
tomber la langue pendante vendaient leur
âme pour un peu d'eau pour un peu
d'ombré en criant laissez moi tranquille
je deviens fou le raffiner poblete
l'oeil clair implorait au passage une
excuse pour ses jambes mais malléjac ne
réfléchissait plus que l'incohérence
comme un miroir qui en a trop vu et
stable 1 ce qui avait le meurtre dans le
regard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la seule pensée qu'on se livre à l
escalade que pour redescendre ensuite
sensiblement vers le même point de
départ souligne l'absurdité de
l'entreprise
n'avait-elle pas vraiment d'autres
objets plus profond un sens caché
louison bobet détenait le fin mot de
l'histoire
[Musique]
le tour est quand même une invention
assez formidable parce que il ya la
durée ya la respiration et les hauts et
les bas
il ya le plat et les côtes il ya des
moments d'arrêt des souffles longue
souffle court parce que le un match de
foot ou de tennis et que c'est un acte
de théâtre mais elle a cet homme c'est
un roman est un roman comme les comme
les romans fleuves quoi alors ça c'est
tout de même ça en soit il ya une un
terrain intérêts humains s'ils ont pillé
parce que l'individu peut se transformer
pendant pendant le tour de france
gérard qu'un match de football du début
à la fin le type soient très différents
oui c'est une c'est encore c'est un
roman le tour de france un peloton qui
s'en va c'est une page qui se tourne
et comme c'est pour la dernière fois
c'est un livre qui se ferme 1956 raphaël
géminiani membre de l'équipe de france
risque une interdiction de départ son
intention d'afficher sur ses cuisses
arts le nom de la marque d'apéritif avec
qui il s'est associé en tant que
fabricant de cycles et pour laquelle il
court l'année durant provoque les
de jacques goddet toutes les marques
avaient tourné de l'oeil
pourquoi parce que à ces progrès a été
battue en brèche par puisque était
motorisé c'était le solex
c'était la mobylette c'était la vespa
tout le monde est de nouveau autorisé
et là il ya des faillites retentissantes
action la perle métropole dilecta
eliette terreau rocher toutes ont à
l'oeil
donc il ya plus de soutiens financiers
déjà on était assez peu pays mais rien
n'a plus donc moi je dis legacy a plus
les marques de scie qui nous payent qui
va falloir que l'extra sportif ce super
pas se superposent et remplace la marque
de cycles défaillante depuis 1950
gaudet avait déjà dû déroger au principe
de des granges en permettant que les
coureurs arborent sur leur cuissard le
nom des marques de cycles qui les
employaient le restant de l'année
les choses changent du tout au tout
lorsque des marques de boissons
d'électroménager sollicité par des
fabricants de vélos aux abois veulent
s'immiscer dans sa course
jacques bonnet était contre les
transporter vos départs pas celui parti
d'un principe que s'il extra sportive
née au coureur
c'est une publicité qui n'allait plus
journaux vous organisateurs donc ils
n'ont rien comme concurrents et pas
complémentaires j'ai eu peur j'ai eu
très peur je ne suis dit que doute tout
c'est foutu au départ dans les années 20
et d'avant guerre dans la guerre le
première guerre on est marxiste
elle est partie c'est comme des clubs
cette partie de la tradition très ce que
ces gens là ça raphaël des apéritifs
tout tout tout ça m'a tout fait à sousse
hammam a fait mais a fait terriblement
peur et puis on a résonné quand même
chago d'endesa a coûté mais il faut que
les stratégies vous verrez que des
strapontins va apporter à bien et
effectivement pompé est venue après il
ya eu la chicorée leroux qui est venu il
ya eu belfort qui est venu puis
finalement ça a mené mais très sportive
raphaël géminiani réussi à faire plier
les organisateurs mais la lutte entre
godet et les marques extra sportives ne
fait que commencer
son accélération va aller de pair avec
explosion du marché de la télévision
cinquante mille récepteur vendus en 1950
un million cinq cent mille en 1959 des
arrivées d'étapes sont réalisées en
direct dès 1958 la remise de bouquets et
l'interview des coureurs provoque alors
d'étranges bousculade et à la télévision
il ya une publicité clandestine qui se
manifeste par la présence de gens qui
sont elles arrivées qui savent que les
caméras tu es mieux en chambre dans un
chat un axe qui savent que on va
présenter le le champion dans ce plan là
et qui est arrivé avec des chapeaux où
il ya écrit perrier péri en particulier
et alors vous pouvez pas les virer il
est très fort c'est très dur
on a beaucoup de vent et beaucoup des
faux plats mais vous avez été renseigné
sur votre position et avec une ampleur
lisez ça il y avait aussi de la mairie
la clavette lors vous ramener à la
petite bouteille alors lui il était
costaud lui s'il arrivait à se faufiler
et alors tu voyais qu'a pu donner la
bouteille à boire il a tout donné
toujours à la bourre 116 vers quoi on a
été un peu complice de ça parce que tout
coureur qui buvait son père ya la télé
est touché et toucher au coeur de saint
barth
un peu comme ça le 14 juillet 1959 la
télévision s'installe à mi-course d'une
étape expérimentant pour la première
fois un dispositif de direct qui a ni
l'hélicoptère à des caméras fixes et au
talent d'un formidable tchatcheur
une diminution moins six minutes ce
qu'ils aient une vie déjà ceux qui
suivaient sommes au sommet n'attendant
vous attend dès maintenant avec nous ce
battage des coureurs que je vous rassure
tout de suite ne vous impatientez pas
outre mesure ne soyez pas plus nerveux
que ne le sont les coureurs aujourd'hui
car on vient de nous annoncer qu'ils
avaient quelques 16 minutes de retard
un quart de télévision aimanté gisti
c'est à dire jusqu'à 2700 70 m avec
quarante techniciens et quatre caméras
qui couvre les derniers lacets de la
montée de ce col de l'iseran vous
apercevez une caméra sur une estrade
vous voyez le public ce qu'elle nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir nous ne
sommes pas loin de l'italie des
pancartes y voilà eh bien nous faisant
comme l'ensemble nous scrutons nous
voyons rien venir au bout de notre homme
les objectifs je t'échange bord d'une
route change aucune autre information
que les gens qui à côté de moi temps en
temps un journaliste de la presse écrite
arrêté me disais bonjour et me dit j'ai
ou en été mais enfin je n'étais pas du
tout d une information j'ai été un type
perdu dans la masse des gens et
regardons passer le train ou attendant
que le train du peloton arrive donc il
fallait a toujours rempli crier vais
être en partie en lançant des pâtés sur
la plage
il est possible aussi de faire détonner
avec la nes est pratiquement sûr ces
derniers classés désalpe qui résistent à
la chaleur qui règne entre les autres
mais dans l'ensemble l'europe enfin
voici l'hélicoptère de la télévision
nombreux cameramen qui est là avec sa
caméra portative sa caméra indépendante
il caméra hs qui permettra de nous
envoyer des images iront directement aux
quarts aux pommes et du col de litres
vas-y l'hélicoptère qui est parti nous
suivant avant de récupérer des images
qui sortent de cet hélicoptère homme
j'ai l'occasion de vous le dira
peut-être même deux fois aux trois fois
1 et tout est possible que je me répète
dans ses commentaires qui n'ont pour but
que de vous faire patienter jusqu'à ce
que question est justement vie
apparaissent dans le foyer de nos
caméras et par la même occasion sur vos
écrans de télévision
bah c'est enfin les deux premiers cas
paraît sera prêt quand ces images entre
ensuite directement délicate c'est à
dire que vous voyez en ce moment ce que
les spectateurs massés ici au col de
l'iseran sont absolument incapables de
voir ces deux points suivi par des
motocyclistes dont gisement dit et
christian les deux hommes sont à un
kilomètre du sommet c'est à dire que nos
caméras vont couper maintenant des
images que vous a donné et l'hélicoptère
va-t-il attend les hommes de tête des
pelotons baham en tête volent bas en
tête et gaulle qui lutte pour le
classement du meilleur grimpeur ses
gaules qui offrait une planète sans le
prendre davantage sur parade en tête et
que gaulle sera un tableau des camps
vous
luxembourg il doit y en avoir encore dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il reste près d'une centaine de
kilomètres avant hausse de nouveau en
direct gens qui taf comme entre elles à
rêver mais la télévision ne peut pas
techniquement montrer les
rebondissements de la course entre ces
deux points et doit dans l'attentes
interrompre son programme
en 1959 un seul média est alors capable
de rendre compte instantanément de la
course où qu'elles se déroulent
c'était au moment de la fenaison de la
moisson en meute et les boissons dans
une source d'eau fraîche et tout et puis
on prenait cette pause et on écoutait le
tour de france
celui qui écoutait ça ils étaient ils
étaient fascinés mois jeunes sportifs
c'était le sommet c'était le père noël
j'étais une deuxième période de la radio
commencé à émettre en roulant et bon ben
on était là 24 enfin pas 24 heures sur
24 mais du départ à l'arrivée de la
course
fallait y être présent et être capable
d'intervenir
[Applaudissements]
un autre auteur de l épure 7 et enfin
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas très perméable
c'est la popularisation du transistor
qui fait que le nombre de postes de
radio augmentent en volume considérable
la radio alors ce n'est plus uniquement
un monument qu'est dans la salle à
manger
c'est partout c'est dans la cuisine sur
la salle de vincelles la chambre à
coucher c'est ici à partout c'était une
étape qui arrivait à 3 autant que je me
souvienne et la radio du tour annonce
par la voix de chaque godet général de
gaulle et sur le bord de la route à
collombey et le nous nous arrêterons
pour le saluer c'est quand le tour de
france est arrivé jacques goddet arrêter
la caravane est descendu de la voiture
et ce moment-là de gaudi fait qui c'est
celui-là et europe
c'est la seule phrase que j'ai pu avoir
parce que à ce moment là les gorilles
ont aperçu une micro est leur mort
carrément éjecté et s'est passé à
l'antenne qui c'est celui là avec la
voix de gaulle c'était antoine blondin
rendre à sa façon justice au patron du
tour de france le général de gaulle
dirige la france 11 mois sur 12
en juillet c'est jacques goddet ce
metteur en scène incomparable chaque
godet est un homme très très dur très
dur parce que très rigoureux il
n'acceptait pas ils n'acceptaient pas
l'erreur qu'il n'acceptait pas la
facilité et alors de même que chaque
godet nous disait à l'équipe une erreur
une faute une information raté c'est
inadmissible
c'est lamentable c'est pitoyable si la
course roue l'a25 à l'heure c'était
lamentable pitoyable inadmissible et ça
se retrouvait dans ses éditos jacques
anquetil à la suite d'une étape
pyrénéenne où jacques anquetil des
emplois et sa méthode
c'est à dire qu'ils avaient neutralisé
la bataille hysteria passé et il avait
emmené ce type qui étaient les cibles
emmené comme un troupeau
alors le titre de mon éditorial
le matin c'était les nains de la route
les noms de la route le parcours
légendaire des quatre cols a confirmé de
la manière la plus affligeante que les
coureurs modernes
les concurrents de ce tour en bus
excepté sont des nains oui d'affreux
nains ou bien impuissant comme l'est
devenu gaulle ou bien résigné satisfaits
de leur médiocrité très heureux de
décrocher un accessit pour eux comme
malheureusement pour la plupart de ceux
qui les emploient
le sport cycliste est devenu un commerce
qu'il faut exercer sans risque et sans
peine
l'important étant que l'on se montre en
public le plus souvent le plus longtemps
possible
ils oublient les grandes leçons du passé
certes encore si proches que donner un
louison bobet spectateurs consterné hier
parmi les autres attendant les coureurs
qu'on surnommait géant
[Musique]
voilà le placement est maintenant rendu
officiel de ce tour de france
plus rien ni pour inchangé sur le podium
jacques anquetil et son maillot jaune
avec les initiales hd henri desgrange le
père du tour et la marseillaise ça lui
maintenant la victoire de jacques
anquetil
[Musique]
alors dans le tour de france il y avait
insisté pour qu'un de personnages il y
avait jacques goddet qui était toujours
à l'arrière et félix lévitan j'étais
toujours à l'avant vous avez l'habitude
de dire qu'il y avait d'un côté un
prince et l'autre côté un intendant
général en même temps adjudant chef
capable de faire fonctionner la machine
c'est l'homme de cet élan d'amaury à wil
ça y'a pas de problème
cet élan d'amour complètement mais
c'était l'homme des finances c'était lui
qui faisait rentrer l'argent c'est lui
qui discute avec les villes c'est lui
qui discutait de sa jagot n'est
intervenue que dans la position sportive
de la course et félix lévitan n'a eu de
cesse de devenir directeur général
si on en faisait je crois le
récapitulatif j'essaie apporter certains
beaucoup plus d'idées autour de
fonctionnant à porter jacques goddet et
l'idée essentielle que j'ai ramené au
tour de france si on peut dire idée
c'est la reprise des équipes de marque
c'est moi qui l'a imposé je connais lui
était atone en farouche des équipes
nationales
le 24 juin 1962 henri desgrange c'est
peut être retourner dans sa tombe
cette fois c'est fait la route du tour
est ouverte
cent quarante neuf coureurs sont
présentés au public qui devant jacques
goddet vont prendre les premiers le
départ après une longue traversée de la
ville c'est le premier tour de france
disputée par équipes de marque depuis 30
ans ce tour 1962 et le début d'une
guerre de trois ans que vont se livrer
l'équipe saint raphaël et l'équipe
mercier bp ou plutôt jacques anquetil
est à nouveau venu raymond poulidor
cette mise en scène de duel nourris
quotidiennement par les journaux qui en
font leurs choux gras provoque une
fracture dans le public français qui se
scinde en deux clans irréconciliables
les poly de rist et les en petits listes
au milieu de cette foire d'empoigné un
des meilleurs journalistes de l'équipe
se distingue par sa rigueur d' analyse
pierre chany j'ai une grande admiration
pour un utile alors pour sa résistance
est un phénomène et raphaël géminiani
disais c'est une machine ni ibm et un
alambic
on peut tout lui demander pour son
courage il se plaignait jamais poulidor
riou a eu la malchance de tomber sur un
style c'était vraiment un être
exceptionnel
et puis c'est un garçon qui était
fermier
je dis bien fermiers pas paysan qui
travaillent la terre des autres et qui
va considérer un certain moment
véritablement il était heureux et le
courant qui se sent heureux qu'ils aient
pas dévoré d'ambition ne peut pas
atteindre aux sommets les plus élevés
avec mon doigt des rires je rentre à la
maison sans fracture cette fois ci
recommandé pour les malades et pour les
blessés le tour de france ça va bien
influença va très bien et le public aime
bien le clin d'oeil
or une pile était un garçon c'était très
en ligne sur sa bicyclette
pierrot visage figé c'est un timide
xi a toujours refusé le clin d'oeil on
lui a dit de cesser ce son manager c'est
son entourage le dit souvent tout fait
un geste de lens pour bouder dans la
foule y répondez moi je pouvoir citer
suis pas comédien poulidor va essayer de
s'accrocher à lui pendant quelques
centaines de mètres mais il pourra
suivre la lure endiablé de jacques
anquetil décidément l'homme le plus fort
de ce tour de france
dommage peut être que jacques n'ai pas
mis plus de panache à gagner cette
troisième tour de france car maintenant
il n'y a plus de doute jacques intrigue
va gagner pour la troisième fois le tour
de france
[Musique]
le tour 1964 s'annonce comme l'apothéose
du duel anquetil poulidor 40% des foyers
français sont maintenant équipés d'un
téléviseur la rtf affecte ses moyens les
plus modernes pour donner aux
téléspectateurs l'impression de vivre de
l'intérieur un combat de titans 70 radio
également ses 35 véhicules hélicoptères
et un avion quand on sait qu'un arsenal
extrêmement considère a pu faire la
guerre en tant que réalisateur ou qui
avait fait un tour de france comme
chasseurs d'image dans quelles
conditions vont travailler vos cameramen
et bien les deux cameramen reporter de
direct vont travailler dans des
conditions extrêmement périlleuse vous
en doutez robert les deux chasseurs
d'image de films auront eu à chasser les
groupes humains les choses que nous ne
pourrons pas montrer puisque nous ne
suivons pas toute la course en direct
s'agit de chaque soir le reportage en
direct de l'arrivée de chacune des
étapes
pour cela nous mettons en oeuvre
d'équipements de prises de vues de
transmission extrêmement puissants à
bord de l'hélicoptère de la loi 3 près
de laquelle nous nous trouvons en ce
moment cette nouvelle caméra dotée d'un
objectif à focale variable développe la
retransmission des dix derniers
kilomètres de l'étape brive clermont
ferrand le dimanche 12 juillet 1964 a
été réalisée en direct
mais comble de l'éphémère télévisuelle
l'un des moments historiques les plus
connus de la légende du tour de france
n'a oublié pas été magnétoscopie ou plus
vraisemblablement été gardé seul en
reste aujourd'hui les images filmées
pour le résumé du journal télévisé du
soir et les souvenirs du maître d'oeuvre
de ce direct
mais poupou eu des tirs c'était la
grande forme de poupaud puis poupou
c'était le coureur du peuple quoi avec
le thé porté par là par les français
imaginez-vous aujourd'hui 2002 virenque
maillot jaune
jalabert a à 20 secondes de vie sain ce
serait grandiose
c'était ça deux français à deux
kilomètres de l'arrivée on ne savait pas
qui allait gagner le tour de france
c'est extraordinaire elle cette époque
c'était absolument révolutionnaire de
voir les deux gus en moto qui était là
et au bon moment où il fallait tour à
tour la une se rend-il la 2 / poupou et
après chaque l'hélico qui montre la
différence
il y avait tout y avaient tous été comme
je disais à mes gars à l'époque les mecs
c'est hollywood ça lui faisait rire
évidemment quand ça allait mal
je disais aujourd'hui quel désastre
c'était bouvines
voilà quand on s'est aperçu que ces dix
derniers kilomètres
tous nos lecteurs les avait vus et que
nous on ne les ai pas vus là c'était la
panique
ça a été une panique à un vraisemblable
parce que effectivement parler qu'au
téléphone à nos journaux pour savoir ce
qui s'était passé elle avait vu à la
télévision
nous nous étions partis comme toujours
dans les dix derniers kilomètres à
l'arrivée on n'avait rien vu
chaque internaute est parfaitement
conscient alors c'était mais chaque
collaborateur
soyez le style soyez là l'anecdote la
petite histoire les échos les
indiscrétions on entendait ça a fait
continue plutôt sensée vraiment une
épopée que nous journalistes sportifs
nous chantons année après année
moyennant quoi nous emportons
quelquefois la dérision de certains
critiques qui considère que dans notre
style
nous dépassons la mesure du raisonnable
mais nous croyons nous sourit sportif
nos ordinateurs que ce doit rester une
épopée qu'il faut traiter sur le mode
et il avait raison car c'était le moyen
de lutter contre la télévision qui
apportait en quelque sorte le film de la
course et il est beau jeu commentaire
donc nous il fallait est complémentaire
de la télévision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'étrange lucarne est en passe de damer
le pion à tous ses autres rivaux
médiatique suscitant chez les plus
pessimistes la crainte de voir le public
du tour leur clientèle de lecteurs ou
d'auditeurs se métamorphoser un
téléphages exclusivement auprès demandé
à sempé ou à plantu de faire un dessin
où l'on voit le tour qui passe dès que
le pauvre coureurs livrés à eux-mêmes et
puis tous les gens en fait volets fermés
en train de regarder la télé et volets
sérieux il ya trop de soleil
bon mais n'ont donc c'est un sport qui
voit et qui est qui et qui s'écoute qui
se partagent oui donc je crois que les
encouragements des des spectateurs c'est
c'est aussi une forme de compréhension
si un coureur tombe ils sont tout le
monde va le court pas les ramasser et
moi j'ai gardé en mémoire c'est ces
photos de nous on voit tom simpson où on
voit mal et jacques où on voit rivier
enfin tous et je dirais tous ces martyrs
j'allais dire du vélo à il ya toujours
bien toujours le public ça c'est ça se
passe toujours avec des témoins leur
souffrance des cours je crois que c'est
pour ça qu'elle est belle aussi parce
que d'autres peuvent en parler
le 13 juillet 1967 2 kilomètres avant le
sommet du ventoux il fait une chaleur
caniculaire
l'ancien champion du monde l'anglais tom
simpson qui participe à son septième
tour de france des failles devant
l'objectif d'un cameraman reporter les
moyens du direct focaliser sur l'avant
de la course sont dans l'incapacité de
couvrir l'incident
[Musique]
l'impression qu'il doit se passer
quelque chose
je pense que le fait que j bernard
yagues avec l'autre ailleurs nous ramène
au sommet du mont ventoux 1 signifie
qu'il ya eu un accident de tom simpson
nous dit on c'est un évanouissement dont
il était victime tom simpson sans doute
dû à une insolation à 150 mètres du mont
ventoux
difficile en tout cas là cette
évacuation très pénible assister à cette
image de l'hélicoptère qui emmène nothum
simpson loin de tout loin de ce tour
qu'il quitte à bientôt tommy
tom simpson décèdent d'un arrêt
cardiaque à l'hôpital d'avignon à 17h30
la presse dès le lendemain évoque le
d'opinion
[Musique]
elle boit mais que je pense que c'est du
fait qu'on arrive en compétition à
l'intensité l'effort halal halal
battements du record plus en plus grands
est-ce que la physiologie normale peut
s'y adapter je pense qu'on n'en sait
rien encore c'est pour ça qu'il faut
absolument voir lorsqu'ils épais bas et
tout est la cause la vraie cause que les
bruits courent que je sois une chance
depuis on n'en sait rien du tout le sera
après l'enquêté
vraiment je ne pense pas que les
conséquences peuvent être graves
mais elles peuvent peut-être être utile
un accident un accident sa part tient
malheureusement à toutes les catégories
de ces grandes opérations publiques et
je vois là dans le journal de ce matin
neuf alpinistes tuées dans les alpes il
ya eu ces pilotes qui sont morts dans
les courses automobiles
tous ces derniers temps et par
conséquent vous appartient à ces
manifestations
votre post moderne et sont utiles ou pas
l'autopsié pratiquée sur le corps de tom
simpson révélera des traces
d'amphétamines dans son estomac
merci
je vous assure que le lendemain matin au
départ personne n'avait le courage de
reprendre la route et c'est là qu'on a
décidé d'un commun accord de faire de
gagner un anglais et c'est barry hoban
qui était le plus représentatif est
peut-être le meilleur qui a gagné
l'étape mais ça a été très très
difficile à vivre
donc c'était pas interdit d'en parler
librement avec les coureurs pour
certains ils nous ont parlé d'autres ne
s'en perd déjà mais jamais par exemple
louison bobet n'a fait allusion à sa
revanche avec géminiani sté courant
savez ce qu'il prenait 9 me suis chargé
un cri bien on en parlait alors c'est
très bien que rivière c'est s'est
suicidé il cesse et intoxiqué il 70 de
risques qu'ils prenaient nous montrait
un dimanche de juillet 1960 7 ans avant
la sphère simpson roger rivière favoris
du tour n'arrive pas à freiner au cours
d'une descente à tombeau ouvert dans ses
poches
on découvrira des cachets de pâles fiom
un puissant analgésique d'autres
affaires suspectes ont émaillé le tour
comme la défaillance de jean malléjac en
1955 où le malaise inexplicable de
plusieurs coureurs avant un départ de
luchon en 1962 mais aucun de tous ces
incidents entraînant le décès d'un
coureur
en 1966 un an avant la mort de simpson
les premiers contrôles antidopage
inopinés impulsée par le docteur dumas
est diligentée par les pouvoirs publics
provoque une grogne généralisée du
peloton
[Musique]
l'anc il y disait moi mon corps c'est
moi je suis dit je raconte ce qu'il
disait un ami cher quand tu bois de
bouteilles de beaujolais je vais pas te
dire ça va te faire du mal à la santé
abel nîmois foutez nous la paix je me
donne tout le monde se doit il l'a fait
de l'ombre à jacques je tenais la porte
alors donc je peux te dire qu'ils
étaient complices
le tour de france depuis sa création en
1903 a dû faire face à de nombreuses
crises qui toute menace et la
crédibilité morale de l'épreuve la mort
de tom simpson
outre le débat sur l'intégrité physique
du sportif de haut niveau relance aussi
la question de l'égalité des chances
entre les coureurs cette règle d'or
instituée par henri desgrange continue
d'être la garantie majeur du succès
médiatique et populaire de la course
vittel son casino ses habitants et ses
curistes ont été les témoins du départ
officiel de la première étape du tour de
france et c'est le départ officiel qui
est donnée par jacques godet directeur
de la course
jacques goddet et félix lévitan je
croise ce fut la première fois convoque
tous les coureurs au départ leur font un
speech viril et nous annonce qu'il y
aura des contrôles antidopage
tous les jours à l'époque la le produit
dopant incriminés étaient l'amphétamine
on a on avait lu que sans doute simpson
était mort en partie à cause d'un usage
d'amphétamines dont il ya eu des
contrôles que dizaine soit en vitamines
et il ya eu dans ce premier tour 68 des
coureurs qui ont été écartés du tour on
a l'air de découvrir que le cyclisme n'a
jamais lutté contre un dopage mais ça
n'est pas vrai il a été le premier à
lutter contre le dopage
[Musique]
limoges qui a donné le grand départ au
tour de france à effet également une
étape du tour d'europe d'europe 1 100
ans en cette fin des années 60 la
maîtrise du récit de la course par la
télévision oblige la radio à mettre les
bouchées doubles pour conserver sa
clientèle
il y avait le soir du podium japonais a
aussi donné cybernétique
je vous aime bien ça à déménager c'était
extraordinaire
ce podium qui se dépliait à puis c'était
vraiment là ça leur est égal
il y avait dix mille personnes devant
parce que y avait pas la télé quand même
pas il y avait moins d'émissions de
variétés donc les gens voulaient voir
les vedettes
il tombait des cordes y avait dix mille
personnes arrivées pas appris mes
origines il personne
[Musique]
zen de milliers de supporters belges ont
assisté à la victoire des limmex à paris
ils étaient venus au toc à un auto ou
avec trois trains spéciaux dans un de
ses traits la maman des villes qui aller
savourer le triomphe de son fils
[Musique]
tours a été inventé en 1903 trouve on
dirait qu'il a été inventé pour la télé
elle n'est pas magnétoscope t elle n'est
pas filmé elle est indirecte
je propose les bleus quand même on l'a
perdu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en ce moment cette politique de
l'enfance d'un sas in vino bonjour
bonsoir nous sommes à plumelec dans le
jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]